hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the creek in the caves
[Music]
at this time yes there you go
at this time
of all cell phones please keep table
talk to a minimum and refrain from
pickling the comedians during the
performance and now i'm proud to present
your host for the evening please put
your hands together for mr hodge
[Music]
what's up potential deities how are you
guys doing tonight
okay
uh i guess no one really wants to get
laid that bad
but we're gonna have a good time uh so
far no one has signed up someone has to
sign up or else the show cannot happen i
know you're i know you need a date
you want to sign up oh look a female
so hopefully that'll entice some people
to sign up and then we're gonna
interview them and uh wants to go on a
date for
60 seconds and then interview them
uh it's gonna be fun so please someone
sign up oh here we go
thank you sir
i really needed this
what what is that that's the purple
ribbon
oh there you go thank you for signing up
we we're going to have a great time now
we got some people coming up this is
going to be fun
my name is hans kim i'm a kill tony
regular no big deal
uh there's only three of those in the
world uh but i'm one of them
and uh i recently got back from florida
i am very happy to be here
you know floridians
are very dumb i thought texans were done
but floridians really take the cake
uh
there's beautiful beaches there and it's
it's very cool
but anyways we always have a guest on
this show this week's guest is a very
funny female comedian please give it up
for isabella carosa
from italy
here we go isabella with the wine
already set up oh yeah i was like i
don't want to finish it before i get up
here
you want to sip along with the show
please drink at your own pace
the show will be fun if you're drunk um
we need more men to sign up which is
kind of weird
if only there was a man in here
i'm looking at you sir with the beard
i know you identify as a woman but
tonight you're gonna have to
[Music]
play your beard's role
uh but yeah how's your dating life been
this is a dating show
from my dating life last time i went on
a date i ended up getting a yeast
infection so
[Laughter]
it's how it's going i don't really date
often
does that happen is that like a thing
that women go through yeah
yeah i mean is it i don't know maybe
it's just me no
no maybe it's not a thing that women go
through
i heard cranberry juice helps
yeah vodka crayon
okay
well that's the limit of my vaginal
knowledge
you're gonna have to go to a doctor for
that one
but we're gonna get a
straight couple up here for the first
one a lot of people
don't want to really date men
nowadays sorry about abortion
we got lorena reyna coming up
and the name that rhymes han train
canteen canteen
someone named canteen
can time
lorena yarena and
can tine cantine who wrote this
this just happened
lorena yana signed him signing up in the
men bucket what no i signed up
oh
well who's cantine
no cantine coming up that looks like a
cantine in the striped shirt no
what how would you read this
caroline
yeah
oh
caroline
your r's look like n's
that or i'm just super dyslexic
look at this o doesn't have any space
it's just a dot
caroline
why did you cross your l's
[Music]
no
english only
english only i i don't even know what
the [ __ ] to do if that's like i mean
apparently neither did i put my name in
the wrong bucket
was your name lorena
come on work with me here
lorena my name is lorena woods
all right lorena what do you like to do
uh hike
hiking is fun yeah what do you like to
hike
the green belt
that's basic
yeah
let's think about something else
she's dating the crowd
let's go further you
like sedona
arizona
that is sedona yes uh i've never been my
friends got engaged there though have
you had dreams to go there no it seems
increasingly less likely i'll be engaged
i'm putting my name in the wrong bucket
your bucket needs to be more full than
it is all i have to say and time give it
up for lorena
reina and caroline caroline
caroline
i hate to sound like a cop but have you
been drinking tonight
i have
wow
you're holding it well
what uh
what made you think that uh
spanish should be the way to go for this
lesbian date i guess her name is lorena
okay well she is in america
what's uh what's your favorite part
about the spanish language
the
accent on the end
on the end yeah
so they they emphasize the end of every
word yeah it makes it very sexy can you
do a spanish accent speak in english but
it's just with a spanish accent
pizza
a worldly knowledge of your typical
american female
uh lorena have you ever been on a date
where the date started speaking to you
in spanish
yes
and how did it go
almost as badly as that
you're like no
i mean
you know starting with the part that
again wrong bucket but whatever here i
am
well every good accident ends with hey
if you wanted the wrong bucket you would
have chosen the right bugger right yes a
lot of i don't know what you're saying
a lot of people speak to me in spanish
you know first see yeah um
and yeah my family's been here since
1870s
holy [ __ ] it's been a lot of time to
acquire the english language yeah she's
uh really an english native right um
thank you for letting us into your
country no problem
how's uh how do you enjoy the uh
the whole texas thing you lived here the
whole time yeah yeah
and uh when did uh
caroline started moving in probably 19
i don't know you mean like her family or
her whale
preponderance of caroline's
2010
2010. caroline when did you come here to
the great city of austin texas i stamped
in on my horse
baggage and carriage holy [ __ ] on the
years
of
i feel like that was in the margin of
error 2012
2010. okay
but you know 50 years whatever caroline
please enunciate between your words
what 20-20-12 20-20-12 that's close
enough to 2010.
so caroline what is your favorite gender
to go on a date with
hey man
what is your type
hey man
he-man he-man
man man name what kind of man
i like a blonde aggressive
comedian type that doesn't know what
he's looking for
oh
i think he's she's just describing her
date
sam kuiper back there
the blonde comedic type that doesn't
know what he's looking for
what uh what did you do before this
i am a creative director and i work for
renewable energy
so
if you guys want to switch renewable
energy is probably the better way to go
you don't need to be
on anything besides that because the
world is going to [ __ ] i think it's an
mlm right
well the way that you slur your words
together is very creative
uh lorena what do you do
um
i drive for uber and i work at a
different comedy club
ooh
an enemy
so you're just here scouting it out yeah
exactly
so what do you think about uh
caroline she's looking for a comedic
type
that doesn't know what he's looking for
i mean i'm glad she has him he's great
do you know sam i mean like i've seen
him on stage i don't know him know him
would you like to go on
snow would you like to go on a date with
the real man
yes oh yeah
well caroline thank you for coming i
understood about three words of what you
said
i'm sure the captions will pick it up
for you
but uh
thank you for participating and thank
you for putting your name in the correct
bucket yeah you're welcome for caroline
i was the only one that put it in but
yeah you're welcome
i hope you have a safe drive home
uh we got jonathan coming up
here we go
yep you wanted to look at him counting
already
we got jonathan going on a date with
lorena
or should i say lorena
i don't want to be a white woman
yeah it's lorena reyna actually but
lorena and jonathan going on a date for
60 seconds and go all right if you
wanted to ruin the world how would you
do it run the world ruin it ruin it oh
okay um
like natural disaster wise
i don't know volcanoes everywhere
how would you do it
become god okay um how would i ruin the
world um
turn everyone into communists
cool yeah
yeah i don't know you know collapse of
capitalism be bad
doesn't sound bad to me honestly i think
it's going great
pouring capitalism down the drain i like
it yeah not enough i think more
more capitalism maybe
no that's a no-go for me
that's it
um
[Music]
cool are you always so political on your
dates
no no okay
i just bring it out in you yeah yeah
just asking how you'd ruin the world or
economy how would you ruin the world
inflation i guess
end time give it up for this super
exciting biden ted talk
it's jonathan and lorena
this is what happens when reddit meets
jezebel
i hope i'm read it in this
example
i don't know who jezebel is but i don't
want to be read it so he's more like
just so uh jonathan why didn't you have
a follow-up to your question you just
sort of like limp dick the end of that
query
you just heard her answer and just sort
of muttered and sputtered
what uh what what what what kind of
answer were you expecting
annie yeah that was that was about it
i didn't have a follow-up you brought up
the super exciting concept of inflation
yeah that was it that was it what are
your thoughts on inflation
uh i'm just thankful i don't have a car
right now i know it's super enticing in
addition gas prices actually come down
50 cents what a good austinite he
doesn't have a car
he's humble bragging do you have a tv
no
wow what a catch do you read i do read i
actually read a lot he's homeless he's
homeless
lorena what do you think about this
hippie
um i'd have to know if it was backed up
by like actual education or just
like if he is educated by memes
memes are great yeah no memes are great
but like it has to have a foundation i
feel like
is that like a question for me
a comment
comment i feel like you look like you're
in the military
but you don't
have a car or tv so i don't know if you
have that much structure and i am
against superior imperialism so
you don't look like it
yeah
[Music]
it's always funny when a white man asks
a woman how would you destroy the world
as if
you guys aren't doing that already
um but yeah you're very anti-imperialist
uh you're very uh you know like
comfortable with doom and gloom
so what do you think about bernie
sanders and are you vaccinated
i couldn't tell you not enough research
on bernie sanders and yes i am
vaccinated wow he's a cuck
[Laughter]
he'll do anything the government asks of
him besides fight the wars that we need
so badly
so lorena are you uh happy that you
found a leftist
you're not a leftist
oh you're neither you're
i think he's antifa get it
he's not defined by the world we live in
the black hand yeah he lives in a
different world all together burn it
down i mean
i am more happy that he's a guy that i
can understand his sentences honestly i
liked caroline i loved it i liked her
energy
well lorena is happy with the correct
gender this time yeah i mean
you got to take what you can get slim
pickings in austin it's true
it's very true jonathan have you dated a
lot in the austin area no i moved here
about four months ago so oh
a tech bro from where
no uh i was traveling all over
beforehand and up in a van no but my
friends were
i think he came to bomb the tesla
factory which is fair
a domestic terrorist
what a find
i think i nailed it where were you on
january 6th
don't worry about it wrong side
he's part of the antifa supercell that
invaded the capital
it was is that like a super intel he's a
friend so
so what do you guys think you would do
together you know go to a
barricade
that would be a good date idea for you
guys
i don't think he plays games
what do you play
ladies hearts
i mean i take him to a book club sports
i read i go hiking i cycle i rock climb
sounds real imperialist if you ask me
what uh
what what do you like to do do you uh
what's the last what's the last date
you've been on
oh no don't ask me that last date i was
on was like a year ago and i got stood
up
[Music]
will feel bad for you dude
maybe he said something weird first you
probably like the other side
with
politics like aggressive politics you're
probably like let's get and have a
debate is is that how it went that's how
i'm assuming it went yeah i asked if she
voted for trump or not yeah it's just
the opening line well just this man is
meeting up to argue with me like
i think he thinks he went on a date with
elizabeth warren but it was just a
campaign rally
it would be aoc come on
so uh a year ago do you think that maybe
she got covered
[Music]
no
no we ended up meeting up the next
weekend but oh she rescheduled you gave
her another chance
you're like this time she won't not show
up
then you were right
and how'd it go
yeah
it was all right there was no second
date
was it
you that didn't want a second date or
her that that was her i'm not a liar uh
he's an honest loser
[Laughter]
no that's fine you know you're a man you
got to go out there and shoot your shot
once every year apparently
are you uh are you ever thinking about
going out there again you know putting
putting your [ __ ] out in the open
not publicly but you know
what's your strategy you just
go to dating shows and
yeah every weekend every weekend no
is it every sunday
i came out because i was very easily
distracted
he's a comedian oh god he's a comedian
lorena oh god
so that's fine
they're both comedians they're made for
each other do you have a spot or are you
bucket no no i just bucket yeah all
right
he's not the elon musk of austin comedy
he's just a plebe
so lorena what's the last day you've
been on
last date oh
gosh
i had one cancel
for coven
um good excuse right
i would say
cup
it would be pre-covered probably rico of
it down
it's bad i like met somebody at a comedy
show and we
hung out
so like that was kind of organic what
did you guys do and we did go to ari
shavir show together so is that kind of
like a date that's cute i was dressed
like hey baby do you want to go see a
racist jew yeah
i love him
[Laughter]
no it's a great date idea let's hear the
word [ __ ] 17 times
well it was the jew hour you know it was
on on topic we all love a good jew
um so lorena what race was the state
that you oh he was he was white from
tennessee
he was poor though it's not your type
like
southern boys
yeah i mean i like complicated looking
you know like we're originally
ugly
i like a lot of [ __ ] on his face yeah
racially ambiguous i would say where you
can't quite well pin it down let me
introduce you to jonathan i know i i had
high hopes i haven't told he's asian oh
that's pretty good native american
or porter something
no it's just he's just a goth definitely
german i get drunk no
i'm just the hair just the hair
he's got the widow's peak of a germanic
what uh what race are you jonathan i'm
irish in chinese
oh the super rare potato
rice did your parents meet
um in california
the classic place for a chinese and an
irish oh yeah like halfway
you're half white no it's halfway i am
halfway but you're half white
that's half right
[Laughter]
we got a whole white person up here
uh so
you guys uh
what what's your ideal
date situation
if you guys were to go on a date like
what would you do would you hold hands
or
it's a date
would you go to a protest
go to a coffee shop
oh
you are irish
a nice little coffee shop yeah
ready some george bernard shaw maybe be
good
they'll learn a lot with each other
they're gonna
do some research together
what uh what do you what do you think
about the uh economy
jonathan i think it's painful
it's painful you don't even have a car
i know who gives a [ __ ] oh my rent my
landlord oh you you have uh what do you
what do you do for money then
3d modeling
oh that sounds techy
that that was your response that sounds
techy yeah it sounds like you sit behind
a computer yeah that's true 3d modeling
why don't you uh send a really intricate
dick pic to lorena after the show
tonight
although for you it's probably 2d
this is so flat got no girth
no i'm kidding i bet you have a big hog
i bet it's more irish than chinese
uh but lorena what uh what do you do for
money
uh comedy comedy club
yeah
with the comedy club that shall not be
named right do you ever you said you
uber too do you ever like me
met potential men when you uber
you know
um i have done it for a year and i never
got hit on until the last last week and
i got hit on three times
by the same dude no
but in just like i don't know like if my
energy changed or something i don't you
know i blame myself of course but
um
yeah i don't
no one i like
ever hits on me
either
uber or life but jonathan stop hitting
on her dude
that's not that into
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i told a guy i believed in him and
he was like do you want to come and have
sex
that's all men need is to have someone
believe they exist
my mom never did it
telling me about some app idea it was
like a five minute ride and i'm like oh
my god you should do that like i believe
in you and he's like do you want to come
in
men without cars am i right
good point who doesn't want to have sex
with an app developer
you can't find those everywhere
uh what was his app idea um
something to do uh monetizing music
you know for
musicians hey you know the pure
expression of joy and happiness in the
world let's try to make money off of
that
exactly
exactly well i'm glad you told him you
believed in him
he just was like trying to get through
the day
that was the napster of 2022. exactly
so jonathan are you ready to uh say
uh what your
type is
in terms of women
pick her
rhetorical question you said pick
somebody
oh no i just think you would like that
girl oh she says no
no
honesty please do not
terrorize the women
jonathan
no
you have a type
like do you like
not generally somebody around my height
which is so
so easy to find because i'm so [ __ ]
short
you are chinese oh you don't i am shiny
like tall girls
it depends honestly on the personality
but that sounds so [ __ ] cheesy so
like height that's your only requirement
yeah [ __ ] heartbeat like what about
width
[Laughter]
why don't you look for you know like
someone below your height or like you're
you want to look someone in the eye
you don't want to bend over to kiss
anyone you're like you got bad knees or
something i really do have bad knees
though
bad knees
from eating all that rice potato
what uh so what what's why is height so
important to you
it's honestly not i i actually just
started going out to meet people when i
moved to austin
um
i honest to god don't think i have a
type but
you want an answer who is who is your
last girlfriend
like
her name her type her type
yeah her name we might know your social
security number her address yeah who
exactly was it um no she had sleeves um
she was she i think she was a little
taller than me actually like tattoos
yeah
yeah but she was white right uh
i never asked honestly oh my gosh that
never came
you never [ __ ] found out what your
offspring would be you're just like let
me just shoot loads and hope for the
best
yeah something like that well it doesn't
surprise me you dated a girl with
sleeves you look like the lead singer of
linkin park
that's kind of a compliment i kind of
[ __ ] with linkin park yeah
of course you do you're half irish
hans is his type
lorena what's your uh type of music do
you like linkin park like this guy does
oh no
no no this is eminem listening chance
the rapper papa roach
lover
chance the rapper yeah oh so you're into
acid wrap
that's cool anything
rap that i can sing along to jesus with
the melody isn't he like a big jesus
person now yeah yeah yeah
you like christian right man i'll yeah i
love it
yeah
jesus you are half white i know
so
if you had to do a little christian rap
to jonathan right now what would it
sound like i'm not gonna do that
jonathan can you do some screamo emo to
uh
lorena no
just express
yourself i believe in you
oh jonathan resist your urges to
solicit sex right now
we all know how men are
once someone believes in us we just
can't help ourselves
jonathan what's your like
sexual strategy if you were to like
you know try to bed and wed a woman what
would you say to her right now
like if you are trying
that would be that you go up to her so
confidently
[Music]
holy [ __ ] i
couldn't tell you honestly well that's
why you haven't gone on a date in a year
so if you're a cute girl at a bar what
are you gonna do you're gonna you're
like all right i'm gonna go walk up to
her what are you gonna say like it
depends is she
make a comment about something i don't
know
about what just pretend you're in that
situation right now
you're gonna vote for trump
you're gonna ask her how she's gonna
destroy the world
yeah that's why i haven't gone on a date
in a year holy [ __ ]
at least we're helping you out look at
this show yeah yeah
converting one intel at a time
[Music]
at this rate we'll cure the world in
five million years
what uh what what is it that you uh that
you would say do you go up to women a
lot in bars and just
bother them
hopefully not bother them
hopefully not
no i
depends where i am if i'm on rainey
street or if i'm pretend you're at the
creek in the cave at 6 40 p.m
and
lorena is just standing there with a
drink in her hand looking around just
looking for some half chinese half irish
dick
what what would you say to her
right now look at her look at her in the
eye
and just or visualize literally anyone
else just hit on her like you're an app
developer and an uber
i feel like you just whip out his dick i
feel like
i feel like he wouldn't just go for the
words
i'm shocked no i've got nothing pretend
you're a man
with a throbbing sex drive
how does it come out of your mouth when
you need to express your viral sexuality
no oh my god please don't do that joker
laugh to anyone
[Laughter]
well lorena what do you have to say to
john any tips or tricks
um
i mean you could offer to buy somebody a
drink
that's a nice indication that you could
be interested in them
um you could ask them their name
[Music]
comment on your shirt
you know
just generally be a human right
have you tried that strategy
well
no i believe in you you know you just
like gotta get off reddit anymore and i
met like 30 minutes ago
yeah it's been a great time
real
real chemistry going on
i think he's the only man in here
also yeah i think about that she ran out
keep it keep it rolling
well give it up for lorena
jonathan you want to go on another date
yeah
jonathan we'll get you're gonna be so
you're gonna be a baller by the time you
leave
i know you're used to only one date a
year we're gonna blow that record out of
the water right now you're gonna double
your load
we got
pam
coming up
pam she's not only a cooking spray
she's a real human woman
going on a date with the lovely jonathan
who is a human
i think
that's a good selling point
a cyborg
one minute of dating between pam and
jonathan starting now
have you ever dated an asian
no no
no what race have you dated
white latina
uh
netherlands yeah but you're asian and
you haven't dated the nation yeah i know
my parents would be super disappointed
yeah they must be
well congratulations i'm eating
what kind
that's probably a bad question actually
does it matter no
what's your longest relationship
oh that's
three months when i was in high school
yeah
oh yeah
i feel like this is a one-sided
conversation you have any questions for
me
um
no i'm just kind of dying i thought it
was an open mic
all of night sudden they said put your
name in the bucket and time
get up for jonathan we're throwing too
much [ __ ] at him
[Music]
he doesn't want this he wants to go talk
to a bunch of straight white dudes in a
dark room
now he has to talk to women ugg
how gross
jonathan
you said you dated a white latina
netherlands
not at once
what was the netherlands like
nice i don't know i love the accent did
her [ __ ] taste like ricola
no
pam what do you think about this uh very
very quiet boy
i think he's nervous
yeah i think so too
really your friend signed you up
classic friend
get out there girl let's go
well that just means your friend has to
date jonathan too
oh i can't beat it am i no i'm not the
only guy
jonathan you're the town bike tonight
you're the male gigolo everyone's going
to take a turn on you it's like the
bachelor but very low budget it's
[Laughter]
the reluctant bachelor
he wants to remain a bachelor
jonathan aren't you excited
jonathan what's the most exciting thing
that's happened to you in the last year
in the last year yeah probably traveling
around the us and eu with my best
friends
and was your best friend a dude
um
half of them that i was traveling with
them are so you you just went out with a
group of your friends and just traveled
the country
countries yeah
what countries
spain the netherlands
netherlands
uh italy
denmark
czechia
that's what comes to the top of my head
nice he's well traveled
he's been to a lot of places
he's not american
anymore you travel to three other
countries that makes you canadian now
what do you think about this world
traveler he's
cultured i love it
what
what countries have you been to
iceland
mexico canada brazil
you really going far north or far south
you don't like to be in the middle
so where what country do you guys think
you guys would be best at
together yeah probably not somewhere too
hot climates
warm warm
i don't know i'm gonna go to mexico so
well bring some sunblock
thanks you're white as [ __ ]
no i'm sure you're gonna have a great
time in mexico what are you gonna do in
mexico surf and read and that's about it
surfing and reading yeah [ __ ] stay away
i got some reading to do
okay that's lame
uh pam what uh what's your next country
that you're gonna go to
mexico
[Music]
haven't planned it out
just waiting for jonathan to spring the
question already
jonathan let's say you're on a date and
you've really been stricken
and you want to invite this girl to a
nice little vacation in mexico how would
you do it
okay you already [ __ ] it up
she's gone already
jonathan
do you just want to tell a joke you want
to tell three minutes worth of jokes oh
no
what's a joke that you think that
displays your
whole brand
can you tell us a joke oh yeah i can
tell a joke i can tell a really shitty
one i heard the other week
you hear that bite coin just came out
bike coin it's eight times better than
bitcoin
bite coin
could only model a [ __ ] but he's never
seen one
uh
so a bite and a bit
bitcoin bite coin a bite is eight bits
yeah it's a shitty joke like i said pam
he likes crypto
he might have money
i didn't understand the joke at all
i love how he's like trying to help you
out he's like he might have money and
you're like no no no
not at all what do you need to read in
mexico
pam what's your type do you have a type
i do
yeah
what is it him
i actually go for latinos okay
and you're asian i'm half asian half
eight what's the other half hispanic oh
so why don't you go for your asian half
i'm not attracted at all
well what a surprise
another lady not attracted to asian men
at all she added
she really had to throw us under the bus
jonathan
different strokes for different folks i
guess
so what's the last latino that you dated
what do you mean what's the last latino
who is a human being that's from latin
america that you've
had dating relationships with are you
asking about his race
no i'm just asking how he was like what
is it that you found attractive about
him dark and handsome tall dark and
handsome what about short pale and
[Laughter]
with a small dick
he just stumbled upon this
[Laughter]
jonathan may i suggest a handkerchief on
your forehead and a gun in your
waistband i think that pam will be into
you
speak with a drawl hey
what's up pam
i'm latino
that's what she's into
he said if role plays on the table
that's what is i don't know if you guys
heard that
[Laughter]
jonathan
what is your
what is your goal for tonight
literally to get out of the apartment i
work remote so
well congratulations that's about all
you've accomplished
so if you were to go on a date with a
girl what would you say to her
seems very in the moment kind of thing i
don't have the imagination for that well
you don't have to imagine you're on a
[ __ ] day right now
here she is
a girl that hates asian men you have the
chance to change your mind
show us the best of us
be the best asian
this yes man learned
you learned from the previous day
yes i would love to
oh she's in a verbal contract now she
can't pull out he's asian he's gonna
remember that
isabella what do you think about this
wonderful couple i think i think it
could be cute
i think
i don't know i think she might end up
walking all over him but yeah
give it three months
[Laughter]
jonathan do you mind being cheated on
yeah you do
well it doesn't seem like you mind much
but apparently we found your line
uh what would you do if
pam came home with a beautiful latino
man
what would you say to her
have some emotions be in the
moment meisner technique
yeah i feel like that would be it
[Laughter]
well i guess i'm getting [ __ ] in the
ass tonight
getting pegs not because he's into it
but he's like all right i guess
[Laughter]
getting pegged more like getting pammed
that's her name
it's the name of the date you're on
name's pam where are you gonna go for
drinks
he's a nice guy
he has a lot of money
there's no way he's this nice and
doesn't have enough money to back it up
where are you guys going to go for
drinks
well there's a bar across the street
perfect works for me cool
nice they did it
two
beautiful millennials
going on a date
get up for pam and jonathan
tune in next week to see how jonathan
[ __ ] it up
we got an lgbtq day coming up
would you would any of you ladies like
to go on a date with issa quirozo quiros
she put her name in the man bucket a
real reina and then becca
bisexual becca bisexual
we got becca the bisexual coming up oh
look at that and isa the girl that put
her name in the wrong bucket
a classic date
[Music]
what was her name becca
isa and bisexual
bisexual backup
one minute starting now
hi hi
this is kind of embarrassing because i
feel like we're wearing the same outfit
even though we're not really wearing the
same outfit i always wore a black shirt
you should have yeah
this is this is going well already so
your name's becca bisexual your mom gave
you that middle name oh yeah for sure
wow i don't have a middle name blue you
know oh it flows well yeah i don't have
a middle
name that's a fun fact interesting i
have two so that makes up tell me more
what's the other one
um
the other one is not bisexual
obviously
her other name is not bisexual you guys
we're about to learn what it is
my middle names are laura grace laura
grace you have three middle names
back of bisexual laura grace
no bisexual oh okay that was just a joke
i didn't realize that um you guys i'm
tanking up here um
are you from austin
you're not from austin great where are
you from
cincinnati area okay
i hear that cincinnati is really
gerrymandered is that true for the
politics
and becca bisexual laura grace
becca by i just have to ask that's a
very confident how many girls have you
dated
dated
seriously none okay how many have you
[ __ ]
no comment
whoa
it's uncountable
she's out here slaying while jonathan's
in his apartment trying to get out
so uh
yeah uh
yeah you did great on this day you did
you showed more testosterone than
jonathan
yeah i always took charge after putting
my name in the wrong bucket you guys i
really was worried that this was going
to happen and it happened so
here we are that tends to happen yeah
so uh yeah you guys are a great couple
you know if i were governor greg abbott
i'd be very afraid right now of you too
so it looks like you guys are going to
make a poster in march
what are we looking for marching
our reproductive rights okay
reproductive rights armpit hair all of
it cool
i don't have either of those but that's
fine you don't have reproductive you
don't have reproductive no not here
what's wrong with your armpits
no hair there either so whoa yeah
i know controversial take you guys what
happened did you were you in a horrible
armpit accident yeah it called a shower
that happened before
if you go armpit hair it means you don't
shower enough
possibly i don't know
yeah who's to say
i don't shower i have armpit hair
um so
yeah i mean you guys are just out here
dating women
have you ever been on a date with a
woman no
i haven't the last time i was on a date
i was 14.
i'm only 15 now so it's
not that weird it's not that rude who
let her in yeah great question who let
me in you guys you're making you're
making jonathan look like a playboy you
haven't been on a date in
12 years okay offensive i'm 25. um
27. oh my god you guys it's embarrassing
gen c still um yeah
that's pretty close yeah 14 plus 12 is
26. oh yeah well i didn't say i was
smart
[Laughter]
are you uh hispanic unfortunately yeah a
little bit well if you're a man i think
uh pam would be into you
hey pam where's oh there's pam hey pam
what's up
so what uh what what so you you're 27 25
25 20 you don't know how old you are
i'm 25. you're 25. okay and you've been
on a date last day you were on when you
were 14. yeah i am in a deeply committed
relationship oh you found one we'll be
ending shortly though so it's okay okay
you did find becca bisexual
[Laughter]
becca what's the longest relationship
you've been in
um
four years
four years holy [ __ ] you guys really
date for a long time
what uh how did you meet this four-year
dandy
um
we worked at the same
cinema in my hometown
a cinema cincinnati a cincinnati cinema
real alliteration going on there
so what did he say like hey have you
seen the matinee
nah he
i just thought he was cute and started
talking to him you're like i gotcha yeah
it was kind of [ __ ] up though because
he was six years older than me
so
oh yeah men hate that
they're like uh girl six years younger
gross
how old were you when
when i met him i was 17. oh yeah we all
the cubs
yeah
i feel like so many girls have those
relationships where you're like oh he's
so cool he's 25. and then like you
turned 25 and you're like what
he was a [ __ ] loser
well don't tell my 24 year old girl
trying to keep this relationship
together you guys are ruining it
killing it
so you met in a movie theater
you guys saw you know tron together
no
that was like when insidious two came
out
what insidious two insidious two i don't
even remember oh my
and it's like really [ __ ] oh with
angelina jolie
no i don't know
i'm honestly not a movie person so
so what did you do at this movie theater
whatever they told me to do i was 17. i
wasn't trying to take it over or
anything
she was a slave yeah she was so much
are you from austin
she's from cincinnati cincinnati right
we just talked about that is you said
cincinnati is famously gerrymandered
yeah how do you know this
i one time worked in news and i
interviewed a politician from or in
cincinnati and she lost so she's not a
politician anymore you interviewed a
sore loser it sounds like yeah and she
was like this place is gerrymandered and
i was like i don't know what that means
ma'am but let's keep this interview
rolling
that's what jonathan says after every
day
this date is gerrymandered i'm gonna go
back to my apartment for the next year
he's still here look at him
he's getting that stage time we're
competing for the bucket
oh no you did great you did great up
here man you should be proud of yourself
so becca what does uh what is the what
is the uh what is a bisexual
relationship how does it usually go
how does a date go with like how is it
different between a man
and a woman
i heard they're different um
yeah
women are definitely more
like gay i don't know yeah
thank god but
like
just
more
like
nervous i guess like we're both like
nervous usually yeah i don't know if
that's your experience but
no that's not my experience i have no
experience
yeah she's dated the same guy since she
was 14. she's terrible don't do that you
guys that is horrible it's a bad
decision and he's never taken her on a
date since damn it's true
he hasn't well thank you for coming out
tonight this made my day good this is
the peak of my life you guys thank you
guys
i need the affirmation
so how did this 14 year old seduce you
um
so we were in high school together we
were in uh marching band which was very
cool and he was the teacher he was a
student um well i wish uh no but we were
we were standing against the lockers and
he said we're both jewish so we should
date
and
wow now we're still dating but neither
of us are jewish
isn't that weird
he just signed you up for the
concentration camp we like unconverted
each other
by being around each other i think
that's what we did so you're ethnically
jewish but not religious no i'm
ethnically hispanic
mexican
yeah i think that's a lot of people's
problems they like assume these things
and then we just unassumed these things
you know so why did he think that you
guys were both jewish because we were at
the time how did you get rid of your
judaism i stopped believing in god
okay
usually and how do we get this to happen
in a worldwide
scale
um
i feel like texas isn't the right place
for me to voice these opinions hell yeah
it is
who doesn't love a good jew right your
boyfriend a number of people in this
room possibly i don't know
you just outed yourself it's okay it's
one of the worst things you can be in
texas a mexican jew
i'm not mexican but that's also i guess
a bad thing to be
what are you i'm costa rican
oh i feel like i'm being harassed up
here more like costa freaking
stay with a woman i stand by what i said
[Laughter]
so you're on a bisexual date with this
costa rican jew that's in a committed
relationship
what do you think about uh you know
these women that be playing
that be playing games out here
going on dating shows with committed
boyfriends
i've been there so i get it
empathy
you've been the committed boyfriend or
you've been on dates with people with
committed boyfriends i have been in the
same situation as you where i was in a
long relationship and committed but i
don't want to be anymore okay
but i did not go on dates while i was
still in the committed relationship not
on stage at least
for sure
so what would you say to
isa quiroz
to rescue her from the hostage situation
that she's currently been in for over
11 years
um
you just have to rip it off like a
band-aid
right rip it off isa should we call him
while i'm here yes call him i think time
is on we're not gonna and also it's hot
girl summer so like it is awesome yeah
it's like way too hot girl summer yeah
give him a call
right
if we were in the same time zone i would
but this will just be
distance
no i'm just not from here
oh you're visiting i am does it look
like i would survive in this town
obviously
yeah you're a jew
[Laughter]
doesn't sound like you survive here
you're wearing glasses that's what the
communists wear
yeah uh what time zone are you from the
west coast oh yeah you don't want to
call him at 4pm no
honestly does your boyfriend too
um that's a good question uh he's a
music supervisor
she's supporting him financially
i wish he was yeah yeah i know i am i am
i am i do nice yeah
how does jonathan get one of you
sugar mama he's not going to
based on the way that date was jonathan
don't listen to her
i believe in you
you just need to find a becca bisexual
i i spotted a few red flags so yeah what
were the red flags
do i need to disclose them
see i'm too nice i don't want to
embarrass
jonathan
jonathan
has already been embarrassed yes
he doesn't need any more
at this point it's too late
okay i'm sorry jonathan i'm really not a
mean person
um
your longest relationship was three
months
[Laughter]
yikes
that
was a red flag for me
john wayne gacy had a relationship
longer than that
i also know how old you are but
you're old enough to be here so
i feel like you should have had at least
like a six month relationship
right
i feel like that's pretty hard to get a
six-month relationship with the
three-month dick
i'm trying to think of the other ones
sorry um it's okay we know he's a loser
we don't have to talk about him anymore
he's really bringing this [ __ ]
hey i feel like he made this show
he is not only he is the only male
that's been up here so far
so far it's been a bunch of chicks and
she's been she hit those red flags i
thought she was going to be like haha
and she was like no but seriously
we have to talk about this kind of thing
she knows a thing or two about dating
she dates everyone pretty much yeah
i don't know if i could do a
relationship with a woman i feel like i
i don't know that might be better
i feel like less cheating right
yeah
yeah i mean
if peop if someone's an [ __ ] or an
[ __ ] like there's no
it doesn't pertain to gender yeah
it might i don't know i mean it
definitely brings more to one another
but that doesn't disqualify
right
right
ladies
but
this would be cute
i think you guys would look good
together right yeah i'll be here for two
more
lots of days then you're moving here
once you know oh no i'm not that's not
happening
not a fan of austin
i do like austin i think austin is
really fun for the four days that i'm
here
yeah well you came right at the perfect
time during our heat wave
oh is this not normal i thought this is
what it was
it's sort of hot right now yeah where on
the west coast are you from i live in
l.a oh i know i know welcome there's a
lot of you here you know
it's great you know like l.a
you see a lot of bisexual relationships
over there so yeah
i do i live in the the gaborhood so
that's nice west hollywood yeah
that's where it's at you would know it
yep yep i love gay [ __ ]
so uh would you guys like to go on a
relationship or a date with a man
with a human man
is there an option yes
who is it
i'll take it for the team because you're
in a yeah you do it please get me off of
the stage
from
[Music]
los angeles
i'm excited next up we got our erstwhile
cameraman and
a prolific dater
a man who picks
the drunkest women to bring to the show
caroline i'm talking about please get
out for a samuel the man kuiper
[Music]
a one minute date starting now
hello hi hi
um what's your name becca sam nice to
meet you nice to meet you
um
where are you from
no i was watching but i was i was half
in so
cincinnati i'm catching up yeah all
right so you live here now yes how long
two years what do you think
better yeah i prefer that sorry i
answered that for you sorry yeah i
prefer the weather and
sometimes the politics but that's iffy
now i have to understand
you like the politics which like texas
politics like austin politics austin
paul what would be the difference
between
texas and austin i mean i know austin's
a little more liberal right
a little gayer than yeah texas is used
to i think yes and that's what you're
into right all about it keep it weird
keep it fresh
keep it horny
sure
end time
get up for sam kuiper and becca
so uh i'm not done yet you are all about
he's gonna mansplain to her no i'm
curious right so you you said and like
okay
what do you like about austin most i
said horny and you were like yeah
so like
what do you what do you like about
austin because it's not
i feel like i summed it up too quick
when i said horny you were just like
do you go out a lot can you let her
answer the question
let me talk let me talk i'm not done
talking yet
all right you're your turn do we need to
put you behind the camera again
i'm ready
i already forgot what the question is i
forgot to freaked her out she's used a
nice kind woman and you come in here
with all your manly testosterone just
mansplaining
man spreading all over the place i'm
trying to be really nice because usually
i am kind of [ __ ] towards men
okay
okay
well
luckily our cameraman sam kuiper can
take it i can take it for sure he's no
jonathan
hey no
no three month pump you know what i'm
saying jonathan
three months chump no i'm just kidding i
didn't mean it yet
sam is from alabama he's been in a
relationship with his cousin for his
whole life cousin
you're really from alabama i am yeah
gulf shores though i mean
it's kind of alabama
he's trying to qualify his alabamaness
did you go did you go to school in
alabama uh no indiana actually oh way
better alabama 2010 indiana it's like
the harvard alabama indiana university
yeah yeah okay so i'm actually from
indiana but
like right by cincinnati
oh
gosh
he's doing physical comedy now at uh
indiana i went to iupui but both of my
degrees are from michigan oh okay
what did you study
uh
double majored in undergrad
environmental health and health data
science
what do you do with health data science
um
well i was working in scientific
consulting
and i recently changed careers so i'm a
data scientist in ads and marketing now
sam's brain just exploded
yeah it did he doesn't understand any of
the words you just said i heard science
and data and
health
sounds like the devil to me yeah it
sounds like
some witch doctor
were you are you jewish
okay good
good
i said it what do you have against the
jews sam nothing i just they just
they're hot you know
um no like like temperature
what the [ __ ] are you talking about are
you making a constant
are you making a holocaust joke what
kind of music do you like
sam do you want to get over to your side
of the table and have a human
conversation i thought about it uh
i'll go i'll go over here um
where are we where we leave off on
what's your music
i like i like blues
okay
that's it that's good
i mean i like everything that's gonna be
the color of your balls tonight if you
keep this up
i'll be all right
um
like what i like blues i like hip-hop i
mean i like everything but like scream
scream metal i don't know what you would
call it
okay you know what i mean yeah i do know
what you mean but that's it like that's
the only off-limits okay what about you
what do you like um
my favorite band is red hot chili
peppers okay
a little anthony keatis yeah i got you
uh yeah i would marry anthony
um
you would marry him
did you read his book yeah i did read
his book
so the gay stuff doesn't bother you no
i'm gay
but i'm saying like
in alabama that's a deal breaker
no i'm
whatever you i'm saying but like
i'm asking that was a legitimate
question even gay his gay is different
than you're gay is all i'm saying right
people can do whatever the [ __ ] they
want it's not like sam what's the gayest
thing you've done
that was a pretty gay way to sip that
drink
the answer to that question
i just showed you twice two two gay
things i've done
okay slipped out of a straw anytime you
want to answer the question just let us
i don't know what the gayest thing i've
done i mean
you've never like made out with a guy i
feel like yeah is that just mine no i've
never made out with a guy but like i've
done like the old like
peck but like
yeah but like if you're in context it's
not you know what i mean but like i'm
not whatever i'm secure i'm not scared
yeah whatever i kissed a dude before
it's not weird
don't make it weird that other men are
attractive i think that other men are
good looking but i'm not sexually
attracted to other men so like i'm i
could be like
that dude's good looking yeah he's he's
got me beat or whatever but like
or like he doesn't have me be like you
know what i mean
but i what about so what about you i
mean
projecting
can we change the conversation
i tried to ask him about his music and
somehow we were back to
he wanted to talk about how gay anthony
kittis was yeah well i did start that
i just asked because my mom is also like
die hard red hot chili peppers and she's
like all over anthony keatis and like
she has like
uh
choose to ignore
agenda
for for some of the things he does she's
read his book too yeah i'm just asking
for that reason like okay so
[Music]
i was like am i going to be his stepmom
yeah
are you
that's his favorite kind of porn
my dad still lives in alabama so it
wouldn't be off brand i guess
alabama pornhub right now
no beautiful i wouldn't know
well uh not in that situation at the
very bisexual becca would you like to go
on a date with
carissa yes carissa
you signed up for that it was really
great
give it up for carissa
sorry go on a date with
sorry we should
[Music]
you look so upset right and you look so
disappointed
give it up
for
carissa
hi
nice to meet you
nice to meet you it's my first date with
the lady
wonderful welcome this is my second one
so
how's it going for you
going well well
after the last one maybe not but sorry
i'm not in a committed relationship
that's amazing
no offense and i'm not jewish
that's i that doesn't matter to me
do you like brown girls yeah
i like
everyone honestly like as long as you're
a good person and
you have kind heart and
you know don't
vote for trump then we're good you know
let's give it up for becca she's like
you know
she doesn't just swipe
yeah no i'm actually like i'm in there
you know like unless it just says
conservative right away
because like i can't honestly like it's
just too much
in today's age i don't even want to like
start that conversation end time
so
give it up for becca and carissa
she just can't even with these trump
supporters she is bisexual
so when you're swiping yeah how can you
tell if it's a trump supporter off the
bat do you just or do you well they
could put that they're conservative oh
right or um if they're holding a fish
holding a fish
the fish of trump yeah fish
this fish supports
states rights
um yeah i mean uh yeah if they put it in
their bio it's pretty pretty big red
flag
[Music]
yeah if they're like trump 2024 that's
extreme yeah that's not trying to do
that yeah
welcome to texas where are you from
california
i'm from texas oh really
san antonio oh you brought your friend
oh your friend
pam
i did you guys look like sisters you
guys look so much alike we didn't mean
to dress the same
wavy hair you guys have the same style
of tank tops
we ran into each other at zara
and i was thinking why is this [ __ ]
hogging the the pants section she was
thinking the same thing and then we
turned to each other she cut your pants
in half
left you with shorts yes that's awesome
well you know i thought you met at the
rio grande or the back of a box truck
but
uh becca have you ever dated a latina or
latino before
i have not i grew up in indiana so
oh yeah a lot of whites
are you a big basketball player
um i did play basketball when i was
younger but nice
now
you're a hoosier i am unfortunately
carissa's asking
who's your daddy
you know because there's a lot of
paternity tests going around in the
latino community
i feel that they'd be [ __ ]
big families
fans yeah
you're right
carissa what did what would you uh
what's like a piece of advice you'd give
for uh becca here in your native state
of texas
data latina
do you like spice
um
that's my only downfall
but i will try things just bring a cup
of milk with you when you're going down
on her that's it
i will die but i will try it
can you dance
i like to think that i can
i haven't tried any latin dances though
so maybe you could teach me just put on
some foreign blondes and she'll cut up a
rug
that's not my vibe
carissa are you a good dancer
yes
can you give us a little sample of some
merengue yeah
grinding merengue
i can do well okay i went dancing on
wednesday and i pulled a back muscle so
i'm gonna hold on oh
what a convenient excuse you know
funnily enough uh the type of porn that
sam kuiper is most into is called marine
gay so
he's the guy that was on here before
well that is all the time we have for
this beautiful bisexual couple give it
up for carissa and becca
thank you so much
that was that was uh yeah that was uh
you're really helping people find love
i'm excited for somebody like a year
after this show i believe that somebody
will find a partner here finally
somebody will get laid off to this show
yeah
it seems like a ton of people like i saw
them all walking in and i was like
that's what they're here for like that's
what
yeah all these people in committed
relationships
coming to watch people date
but uh anything you want to plug
i you could follow me on instagram at
isabella carosa comedy
give her a follow very funny comedian
isabella carosa
yes
i always never know how to say that
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out good night drive safe
tip your bartender